it was a brilliant day in vik and
without further ado we bring you the
round three rapid recap fiona we could
make no other choice than a game between
daniel dubov and vita gujarati
indeed an early front runner
four game of the year not just game of
the tournament and let's see it started
off quietly with an italian game daniel
dubov he can play anything he will play
anything but he soon sprung the first
surprise
right here he played bishop g5 which is
not the most common move instead
castling for white or other variations
but instead bishop g5 and after h6 he
retreats his bishop and fiona right
around here knight a3 what an odd choice
and vidit talked about it after the game
knight a3 was the first real surprise of
the game for him after some thought he
decided to take the knight on a3 always
a double-edged decision
yes white gets the bishop here but also
a ruined pawn structure here on the
queen side but the game started heating
up where did it he was a bit
self-critical about the move knight to
b8 but it worked out in his favor as he
rewrites the knight to d7 and here fiona
this is where it gets spicy
in the g5 kicking back the white bishop
and vetted now deciding to take the pawn
on e4 which is going to of course open
up all the lines in front of that
uncastle king on e8
as vivid said this is modern chess for
you he takes this pawn on e4 it attacks
the bishop and attacks the pawn on c3 so
dubai plays queen c2 we see another
brilliant choice pawn to f5 if my king's
going to be in danger let's put in all
the danger it can handle and after de5
we saw a trade rook to e1 knight takes
bishop pawn takes e4 and fiona we saw g4
things are heating up and how did vitta
handle this vidit handled things
incredibly well he was already the time
was ticking down but village just
started playing perfect chess he now uh
just ignored this g-fun
g4 push jumped with the knight into c5
and
dubois doing the same bringing his own
knight forward via d4 and rook f8
admitting i'm never going to castle
kingside that was off the table for a
while already but that rook on f8 robert
soon
played started playing a very important
role because what was dubrov about to
uncork here
it was a heroic piece indeed we saw a
gf5 bishop f5 and now this was the first
humongous shot of the game rook takes b7
the point being that after knight takes
b7 bishop b5 is check to the miserable
king if you go king to d8 you walk into
a fork knight c6 check is a problem you
lose your queen if the bishop returns to
d7 rook takes e4 guess what white wins
your queen again that leaves you with
one other option king f7 white snaps off
this bishop on f5 hits the queen hits e4
the bishop can come back to c4 h6 is
under attack e4 as mentioned is
threatened this would have been a bad
news for vidit so fiona instead of
capturing a rook we don't have to
immediately recapture pieces just
because they took hours what a move did
it played here he took some time we were
incredibly worried you don't want to
find yourself uh in this position
against danny lurov who's just
sacrificed a piece but a vidit gujarati
he played the incredibly calm and cool
rook f6 which turns out to be the only
move in the position
i wish i could give that like three
exclamation points and as we were just
seeing in the previous variation that
when this bishop came to b5 with check
the king got in the rook's path but with
the rook here now knight takes b7 is in
fact a threat and duboff said
threat what are you talking about let's
play queen to b1 the knight took the
rook the queen swooped into b7 and
here's where everything broke loose rook
d8 knight f5 rook f5 and fiona from a
distance perhaps dubop didn't see vivid
saving grace here indeed it looks like
the black king is in a lot of trouble
all the pieces are swooping in
we are screwing the queen and the king
rookie five the move you want to play
immediately it doesn't work robert
no it does not you'll see that
evaluation bar goes sky high because
queen c6 check ends the story here if
the king were to go to f8 queen takes h6
with check the queen can go to h8 with
check pick up a rook in the center of
the board he had the rook blocked on d7
queen g6 check if king f8 we just told
you what it would happen queen h6 queen
h8 actually queen g8 is mating one what
am i talking about i can't see the
obvious but instead king d8 the point is
queen g8 check queen blocks no we don't
trade queens we do it on our own terms
because the bishop defends the queen on
g8 we stole a rook in the center that
means white would have been a piece
ahead and maybe the move that vitted
played and
that that duboff might have missed from
a distance the saving grace rook d1
check freeing up that uh all-important
d8 square for the king uh duboff here
stepped out of the jack and now rookie
five is a different story
completely different story as you
mentioned the d8 square is vacated king
f8 would have run to the same exact
problem with the check and queen h8
winning this rook in the center so king
d8 and the fireworks just really started
continuing queen eight check king to d7
bishop b5 check that king goes up to e6
we'll give it another check why don't we
the king steps to f6 and now after queen
h a check it's not losing because of the
move king to f5 fiona
incredible stuff what a king run
by
vidit gujarati and here
is it the moment where daniel dubois
finally took the wrong step robert
it was he made the move f3 which i can
understand because rook takes e5 queen
takes e5 is a check to the king a check
to the queen that would force the queen
trade and black is up a rook for a
bishop so instead of these moves the
only move was queen ca check i can
forgive daniel for missing this because
king takes e4 is not possible queen g4
checked you see the bar go up king to d5
it is not queen takes rook that's the
move that we were all thinking no it is
queen c4 check the king has only one
square and this is sort of a smothered
mate the rook and the queen they block
the king's access to free squares that
is check and mate on the board so that
is what daniel dubois missed and vidit
was missing nothing after that was not
played yeah f3 daniel duboff taking a
wrong step and vidit was just clinical
from here on out with the king that has
been all over the board already now
running for a safe haven all the way in
the white camp it's heading for c1
that's why daniel he didn't try to give
another check because the king would go
to d1 and finally two c1 when there is
no more checks in the position and so
instead daniel tried bishop c6 but now
all that was left to do uh forward it
was to put the finishing touches on this
position
and he made it look easy he pushes his
pawn to g4 one last check king d2 and
that is where the game concludes because
queen f2 check even queen e2 forcing the
queens off the board because the white
queen is pinned to the king that would
end any debate because black is up that
rook for the bishop and we're going to
end our game here that was your round
three rapid recap
an absolutely stunning game we hope you
all enjoyed this recap and not only did
uh vidit win this brilliant game it also
proposed him to the lead of the
tournament he is now in the so lead on
two and a half out of three followed by
a pack of five players on two out of
three among them uh world champion
magnus carlsen world cup winner ian
kristof duda and the fantastic um
hungarian attacking player richard
report andreas panko who beat his fellow
countrymen um sergey karjakin today and
of course the defending champion jordan
van furries who will be playing against
his boss magnus carlsen tomorrow robert
yeah he's gonna say tomorrow you're not
the boss of me that was a one-time deal
only for the world championship but
jordan said it's always a pleasure to
play against the world champion i'm sure
they did some sparring some training
games as part of the preparation for the
match against yonder palmishi but there
are six other games that look equally
fascinating fiona i'm in particular
vidiq gujarati white pieces he's the
determined leader he takes on andre yes
apenko who now has two out of three
after beating his compatriot sergey
koryakin indeed both of them will be
coming fresh of a win and they will be
eager uh to keep the run going and i
think tomorrow is also an interesting
day because it is the last
day before the rest day which is coming
up in just two days so it's always
curious to see how much are the players
willing
to risk so
a lot of new storylines to follow
tomorrow we will be back same place same
time it starts at 2 p.m central european
time that's 5 a.m pacific
robert what a day it has been thank you
so much to you thank you so much to the
chat thank you for watching us
and robert i'll leave you the final
words
well it felt like three days in one and
there were four decisive games so we had
a treat vikanze brings out the best in
many players and it's just such a fun
tournament filled with the who's who of
chess the top rated players in the world
some youngsters like pragmata it was not
his day today but tomorrow the sun still
shines he gets to come back to the board
and try his and best and try to get
another win or not another he hasn't had
one yet but another in his illustrious
career already at just 16. so fiona
thank you so much for joining me i know
it's been a long long day but day four
should just be even better than the
great day three we just had i'm
certainly looking forward to it i'll see
you then i'll see you all in the chat
tomorrow have a good one we'll see you
then take care bye bye
[Music]
you